Joining us now is
the vice chair of the Senate
Intelligence Committee,
Republican Senator Marco
Rubio of Florida.
Senator, thanks so much for joining us.
So you have said
that President Biden
should have shot the balloon down.
Earlier,
the defense secretary, Lloyd Austin,
said, quote, After careful analysis, U.S.
military commanders
had determined to downing the balloon
while Overland posed an undue
risk to people
across a wide area
due to the size
and altitude of the balloon
and its surveillance payload.
And as you heard Secretary about a judge
just a few minutes ago
said that the debris field
after the balloon was shot
down was about seven miles long.
Should President
Biden have ordered that it be
shot down
anyway, regardless of that risk?
No, not regardless of the risk.
First of all,
that they can track these things.
I would hope
you can track a slow moving balloon
that clearly is headed here.
As you can see from its trajectory.
I think that's
one of the things we've learned
this week is how soon,
how late into January?
Did they already know that
there's this high altitude balloon
and what its trajectory was
and where it was headed?
And why didn't they take action
at that time? That's number one.
I think the other thing
that we need to know about it
and understand is
why did it take so long for them
to disclose this to the American public?
I don't think the trajectory
of where this balloon was going
was a mystery.
I think pretty early
on, they probably
because of the prevailing winds,
because of the direction
that it was headed.
I think it was pretty clear
that this thing was going to enter
the northwest in Montana.
In Idaho,
move its way down
the Middle West and exit the
the Eastern Seaboard,
just off the Carolinas.
I mean,
that's an unprecedented flight path.
And why did it wait till Wednesday
to notify air Thursday
to talk about it
to the American people,
knowing people were going to be seeing
this thing?
As vice chair of the Senate
Intelligence Committee, do you know?
Has the U.S.
recovered any parts of the Chinese spy
balloon has them?
And did the monitoring of the balloon
during its journey
as far as, you know, yield
any worthwhile information for the U.S.
Well,
we won't know that
until we get into a secure
setting this week in Washington.
And probably most of that
is something we won't be able to disclose
in any great detail.
Other than to say this.
And that is that,
you know,
they're going to try to recover this.
Apparently, it's in shallow waters.
We'll see what they recover from it.
But I don't think the technology
or the existence of these things
is a great mystery.
I think what's embedded
here is a clear message.
It's not a coincidence that this happens
leading up to the State
of the Union address,
leading up to Blinken's visit to China.
The Chinese knew
that this was going to be spotted.
They knew that
we were going to have to react to it.
They flew it over.
Military installations
and sensitive sites are crossed
right across the middle.
I mean, look at the flight
path of this thing.
It's a diagonal shot right
through the middle
of the continental United States.
And the message embedded
in this to the world is
we can fly a balloon over airspace
of the United States of America,
and it won't be able
to do anything about it to stop us.
They calculated this carefully
with a message embedded in it.
And I think that's the part
we can't forget here.
It's not just the balloon.
It's the message
they're trying to send the world
that we can do
whatever we want in America,
can't stop us.
What information
do you think the spy balloon
might have gleaned as it as it traveled?
I know it was over
the fears that it was over some U.S.
military installations.
I'm also wondering if infrastructure
was probably part of the surveillance
task it had
Well, again, it would
be speculation
other than to tell you that those things
usually at that altitude
and what they're doing
is probably trying to collect
on signals on electronic information
that's transiting
that they can pick up on their various
other means,
that they can do that as well.
And that's why
I go back
to the whole point of the message.
There are probably other ways
that China could acquire
whatever they acquired
using this balloon.
I may be wrong
there may be some unique attributes to it
that I'm that I'm not aware of yet,
but we'll learn more about this week.
But I think more than anything
else, beyond
just the ability to collect information,
it is the ability
to send a clear message.
And that is
that we have the ability to do this.
And America
can't do anything about it
if they're not going to be able
to stop a balloon from flying over U.S.
airspace.
How is America going to come to your aid
if we invade Taiwan
or take land from India or take islands
from the Philippines and Japan?
And I think
the fact that they would do that
leading up
to State of the Union,
leading up to what was then
Blinken's scheduled visit,
none of that is a coincidence.
So we need to understand
clearly there was messaging behind this.
But you so
you think that first of all,
I guess there are two parts to a question
I have following up on that.
One is
the Pentagon
says that they know of the Chinese
doing this at least four other times.
Previously, once at the beginning
of the Biden administration,
three times
during the Trump administration,
it seems to be you're saying,
oh, you're saying, no, that's not true.
But in any case, is that is the no.
What's the defense?
Okay.
Well, the difference is this.
Are we aware?
Have we seen the Chinese fly
these balloons in the past?
Yes.
I think there's even
Twitter pictures of it
flying at one point
off the coast of the US down
south somewhere
that the existence of the balloons
is not a mystery to people.
And in that field.
What we've never seen,
what is unprecedented
and whoever the source
was at the Department of Defense,
would have to acknowledge just
what is unprecedented is a balloon flight
that entered over Idaho
and flew over Montana
over all
these sensitive military installations,
Air Force bases, ICBM fields
right across the middle of the country.
That has never happened before.
That is unprecedented,
that it flew briefly
over some part of the U.S.A. U.S.
That's one thing
but what we saw this week,
it's unprecedented.
And that's why
everyone's reacting the way
they're reacting. We've never seen this.
So this is no comparison
to anything
that may have happened up to this point.
Your colleague
and friend,
Republican Senator Tim Scott of South
Carolina, accused
President Biden
of, quote, dereliction of duty
by allowing the Chinese
spy balloon to fly across the U.S..
That's a pretty strong accusation.
Do you agree with that?
Well, I think the
dereliction of duty begins with this.
Why not on Tuesday or Wednesday?
You know, people are going to see this
at some point.
You're going to have to disclose it.
And they probably didn't want to
because they didn't
want to have their hand
forced on canceling this Blinken visit.
And so they didn't
so they didn't
want to have to talk about it.
But why didn't the president
go on television?
He has the ability to convene the country
and cameras
and basically explain
what we're dealing with here
and why he's made the decisions
he's making and what they intend to do.
I don't understand.
Once they get went public with it,
knowing the amount of interest
this was going to generate.
Presidents have the ability to go
before camera,
but go
before the nation
and basically explain
these things early on.
And his failure to do so.
I don't understand that.
I don't understand
why he wouldn't do that.
And that is the beginning,
a dereliction of duty.
And the second is
we have to act swiftly on these things.
I think that's part
of the one of the things
the Chinese are trying to message
and that is
the US had to see this coming
and decided they couldn't or wouldn't
do anything about it early on
and now had to wait
until this thing
went across the middle of the country.
And and what are we going to do
the next time this happens?
Are we going to allow it
to fly through here again
and shoot it down
once it gets to the East Coast?
I mean, these are questions
the White House needs to answer.
And I don't think these are partizan
claims I'm making.
I think there would be a broad agreement
that we need to know.
Moving forward
what our policy is going to be
with regards to this.
So, as you noted, Secretary Blinken,
did cancel his trip
to China
after it was disclosed that this balloon
was was flying over the U.S..
What additional consequences
should there be for the
Chinese government now
Well, I think the
first consequence has to be
we have to decide
what are we going to do
the next time
one of these things had to this way?
Because I don't think
it'll be the last time.
I think you'll see it again.
Beyond consequences.
I'm not sure there should be
a direct individual consequence.
I think the broader relationship
between the US and China
to anyone who has any doubts about it.
Now, the bottom line is here, and that is
we are now
China has been for some time and will be
the primary strategic
adversary of the United States
and we should be focused on it
because what they're trying to do
is create a world
in which they are
the most powerful nation
and the United States is a great power
and decline
that that is
that is what they believe to be the case
That is what they are working on.
And we have to determine
whether we're going to allow the world
to head in that direction or not.
And then there's all sorts of things
we need to do
from how we're postured militarily
in the Indo-Pacific
all the way to
what kind of companies do
we allow to operate in the United States
and spy on us?
Because we've invited them in,
because they're in our infrastructure
and our telecommunications
infrastructure,
because they're buying land
because they're buying farmland,
because they're
because they're wiping out key
industrial capabilities of this country.
There's all kinds of things
that need to be discussed
when it comes to China,
because this is the issue of the 21st
century.
The Chinese government says
now that the US has shot down
that balloon,
they reserve the right to use
whatever means they want to deal with any
any similar situation.
There's even talk in the Global Times,
which is basically a Chinese mouthpiece,
that that shooting down
what they say is a civilian balloon
that's a dangerous precedent and they
might shoot down
U.S.
civilian apparatuses.
What do you make of that?
Are you
are you
fearful at all of this escalating?
Listen, if we were to fly anything over
China, they're going to shoot it down.
They're going to shoot it down
and they're going to hold up
and they're going to take pictures of it
and they're going to go bonkers about it.
So I don't know what statement
they're making.
You can't
you can't fly anything over
China now anyways.
I mean, if we were to do that,
if we were to fly a balloon over China,
the Goodyear blimp flew over China,
they'd shoot it down.
So it's it's a
it's what they do over there.
It's it's silly talk.
Bottom line is, I think that's that's
that's what we should expect anyway.